[Music]
what's shakin reject nation it's John
here come to check out a brand new movie
trailer this was sent over to me I
didn't realize this movie was the thing
and then I took a look at the
description and got intrigued because uh
you know I like the spooky stuff I like
some good spook comes every now and
again and I actually heard about the
subject of this movie a little while ago
and I didn't realize that a documentary
or whatever this is was gonna get made
at all I just thought this was something
that the Ghost Adventures people were
doing but but we'll talk about that
after the trailer for right now let's
let's hop in and see what demon house is
all about quintessential time-lapse and
[Music]
my Zach pagans I'm one of the world's
leading researchers on ghosts and demons
and this film is cursed
ah a story about a demon possession
makes international news look at one of
the most documented cases of demon
possession and exorcism in recent
history
the next day over the phone I buy the
house see my 37 years of police
investigation I've never run into
anything like this before
I just got the keys to demon ass either
gets dangerous for me to be
[Music]
[Music]
people are making this up I'm gonna
[Music]
Oh what what just happened okay all
right uh interesting I was not expecting
what that is I can't quite tell what
this is well is this a documentary or is
this a narrative film disguised as a
documentary is I guess what I want to
know after buying a haunted home in
Indiana over the phone sight unseen
paranormal investigator zak bagans and
his crew are unprepared for the demonic
forces that await them at the location
referred to as the portal to Hell um did
you know I can't I just can't I can't
quite tell and I feel like I know that
this house does have a certain history
of haunting I remember reading this
story back when he first bought it and
then I think demolished it right I'm not
one to just poopoo the idea of a house
that might have spooky happenings this
trailer makes it look utterly insane
though not that that's a bad thing
perhaps it certainly looks thrilling it
certainly looks fun in a way but I can't
help but wonder just having seen so many
ghost shows and having seen you know
films at least based on real hauntings
and stuff I'm super curious as to what
level this is playing on and how much of
its gonna be actually real if it's
supposed to be actually real because you
know I'm sure there are some really
interesting tidbits and interesting
people to talk to about this some
interesting experiences to have shared
but this trailer has so much in it that
I just cannot tell the the exact nature
of and so that that makes me a little I
don't know skeptical or something it
looks cool though I mean I've seen a few
episodes of Ghost Adventures and Ghost
Adventures always makes me chuckle in a
way just the demeanor of those dudes I
think is kind of funny they are just
kind of like dudes you know but who are
checking out you know haunted stuff and
you know investigating either way just
as a trailer this certainly grabbed me
that this sound mix I feel like is a
muddy
but but you know there's certainly all
the requisite like creepy tonal mood
shots and stuff and moments of mayhem
intercut with you know religious
iconography and then and stuff like that
so you know at least in terms of a
paranormal trailer of any kind is it's
certainly grabby so what do you guys
think are you guys excited do you want
to see demon house do you want to go on
a ghost adventure with zak bagans hit us
up in the comment box and let me know
and otherwise hey guys you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or videos out and follow
us on the stardust app link in the
description box check out viewer reviews
calm as well it's like a personalized
rotten tomatos tailored to your tastes
and it's also where we're posting a lot
of our written movie reviews so check
that out and as always guys - Cheers
you